[Musique]
il a 15 ans et ya dix ans quand je crois
fait dans la rue la police débarquer les
gens et m'insultait il crié dessus
aujourd'hui je m'intéresse à évoluer en
fait quand tu as une bombe et tu peins
je regarde ce que tu fais et regarde
plus en fait le fait que tu as une bon
[Musique]
tu vois que c'est vraiment addictif quoi
tu peux pas t'empêcher de laisser la
trace de faire le style de faire un
petit truc est de vous regarder l'espace
que en termes de spots que tu pourrais
pas certain que ce soit mon balles ou
par vos bacs
[Musique]
paris couvert de tags paris massacre est
retourné cartonné comme disent les ta
gueule
[Musique]
on s'amuse productivement n'étant
productif l'otage on s'amuse tout en
étant prédictif tu voyais et des petits
branleurs qui nous passait veut dire aïe
un tag s'appelle comment ils vont passer
dit m non ils vont revoir la même chose
à la fin de la soirée bourrage de crâne
prise de tête
oh mais qui c'est celui-là est comme ça
et mon école
dans les toiles les gens qui les gardent
chez eux les murs à soi si tu as un truc
à dire
de valable
ces parkas essaye de le mettre sur un
surveillant m'appelle jay jay walsh qui
l'ancien graffeurs ce qu'on appelle
pionnier du graffiti ici enfin ils sont
salis grade alors là vous voyez une
poste à l'époque c'était un terrain
vague un des importants lieux du gratuit
site puisque c'est ici que le gratuit
vraiment installés lors de la culture il
faut que tu arrives en france la plupart
des jeunes gens s'est globalement il est
patrouille est rappelé l'orateur tapis
j'aime beaucoup la danse et trapèze du
rappeur ça ressemble au même l'ambiance
qui avait dans les ghettos et noir et
latino de new york là où le gras filet
les jeunes qui étaient issus de
l'immigration les minorités invisibles
ils se sont retrouvés dans cette culture
a éveillé c'est juste d envie d'exprimer
ils étaient 1
quelles étaient leurs préoccupations ces
gens là bas ils se réunissent tous et
pif en une espèce de ce qu'ils n'avaient
pas avant d'une culture la culture
si tu veux comme nos ancêtres auraient
pu la voir mais sur le bitume considère
qu'on est dans le béton pas autant faire
avec les illégalités c'est une façon
encore de dire que ces gens sont hors la
loi alors que pour moi c'est plus une
forme de résistance
on habite dans ces endroits tout pourri
donc c'est à nous qu'il appartient de
pouvoir faire de la pub comme on
l'entend bon ça peut à travers les
graphes ou de les zombies liant et de
faire des expos comme un conte sur des
mineurs mais bin talal groupe à les
saisir at goats voilà
[Musique]
j'ai envie de tailler partout j'ai envie
de tailler partout j'ai envie de tailler
partie sera conclue par contre en format
doit quelque chose de malaise watts à
évacuer tous les efforts étaient
récompensés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je matte a limité avec nos g j'ai fait
du grave parce que j'avais un truc qui
s'appelle le hip hop c'était plusieurs
disciplines et c'était la seule
alternative qu'on avait pour avoir une
activité parce que malheureusement la
rue n'offrait aucune activité à cette
époque la liberté la liberté
moi ce que j'ai aimé c'est le prendre
mais faire un truc alors j'ai autant
aimé le côté illégal
je le côté légal donc j'ai fait les deux
et puis on grandit on a des problèmes
avec la police
[Musique]
moi le côté vandales j'ai dû
malheureusement un petit peu lâché
puisqu'à cause du rap et à cause de de
tout ça j'étais un peu grillé est connu
la réalité c'est que j'ai des enfants et
que je peux pas leur dire que je reviens
pas pour un tacle à nu quoi donc j'en
fais mais un petit peu moins présent
[Musique]
on est tous pareils des graffeurs quel
que soit le site qui fait on a besoin
d'aller perdre gratuitement sur le mur
c'est vital c'est vital parce que c'est
le premier amour en fait tu vois qui est
vachement cool c'est que quand tu peins
on va dire dehors dans un espace urbain
dans un truc qui est comme ça en fait tu
créer une interaction directement avec
les habitants et l'environnement et il
n'y a pas de mensonge et je trouve que
c'est quelque chose qui est vachement
pur tu as le grave c'est un top 10 et
c'est le graffiti qui entre initiés tu
vois c'est les vandales en fait ils
parlent que entre vandales ça s'adresse
pas aux mamies qui voit alors que la
mamie qu elle voit un tweak est un petit
peu bien dessinés à l'ena qui fait vrai
assez cool
en fait la clé c'est que tu fasses
devenu légal ou illégal plus tu es
visible et tu prends ton temps plus les
gens y pensent que telle autorisation
tout était à faire tu arrives en mode
terrain conquis
[Musique]
monde d'artistes kashink ça fait presque
15 ans que je fais de la peinture dehors
effectivement j à une inspiration des
masques parce que c'est une culture qui
est mondial c'est à dire tous les
humains de toutes les cultures du monde
ont une tradition de masques pour moi
c'était important de pouvoir faire
quelque chose que je puisse partager qui
puisse être compris en fait des gens qui
vont passer
[Musique]
la moustache c'est vraiment le grand
classique ça fait presque six ans donc
je la porte vraiment tous les jours ça
surprend toujours de voir des femmes
faire des choses qui sont pas censés
être des choses de femmes tu vois une
meuf en train de peindre est ce que tu
dis direct ah ouais c'est méga féministe
tu vas voir ma gueule tu vas pensée
féminisme tu vas pensé qu'ouvrir tu as
pensé non binarité ça se voir si tu
connais les sujets pour moi c'est acquis
si tu les connais pas et que tu sais
même pas ce que ça veut dire
eh bien tu vas voir ma face et tu vas
peut-être te dira tiens c'est possible
de faire ça ah tiens il ya une meuf qui
peint et j'ai vu ça aujourd'hui
[Musique]
faire des trucs interdits si ça ça aide
vraiment été une des premières
inspirations aussi faire un truc qui
soit illégal mais qui apporte une espèce
de surprises tu vois dans un espace où
les gens passent habite et c'est plus
j'ai eu des commandes de murs plus j'ai
eu des sollicitations pour exposer en
galerie plus j'ai eu envie de faire de
l'illégal à côté en fait parce que
j'avais besoin de cette dynamique là
quoi
je vais pas faire un grave sur un papier
tu vois mais par contre en fait tout ce
qui était recherché ce que tu vas faire
et ce que tu vas prendre dans le
graffiti dans la peinture en fait sur
papier c'est le concentré chez le
résultat final on va dire c'est le
caylar sans quoi là par exemple je suis
en train de travailler sur une expo que
je vais à paris
je suis là dessus donc en fait mach en
train de travailler on va dire les
matières on va dire les mouvements ni
stills le graffiti celi vincent touchera
trick bien bas bien prend la photo va on
efface ou pas la toile sur la toile on
n'efface pas quoi jeter elle est là les
lacroix le festival c'est un concept
avant d'être un lieu et ce concept c'est
autour de la couleur et autour du style
des gens on veut montrer le spectre que
ce que c'est le street art le plus large
possible pour que les gens se disent
waouh
en fait ces multiples ou le challenge
qu'on voulait faire cette année c'est de
se dire et de montrer aux gens que
c'était possible
même quand tu viens de structure et que
tu viens d'un art comme de grands du
coup tu viens d'un truc qui vient du
graffiti député soutient qu'en fait ça
peut être aussi chiadé que
j'ai un boubou ou un truc comme ça c'est
pas parce qu'en fait tu fais du street
art qui jettera schlague avec une une
tireuse à bière et pas faire des efforts
pour montrer ta propre culture je me
suis vu le vieux avec une canne en train
de cracher sur un train je le ferais
important enfin je consignes en mai en
france mais pas fier